contredit pas votre ligne ni droite ni
gauche ça chante lui est plus proche
d'une droite classique
non je crois pas du tout en l'occurrence
je pense que beaucoup de gens ont voté
pour lui à lyon y compris d'ailleurs des
gens qui venaient de la gauche il avait
d'ailleurs sur sa liste les gens qui
venaient de la gauche il avait également
des personnes qui étend sur d'autres
listes avaient appelé à voter pour lui
au second tournant je crois que c'est
vraiment la victoire du rassemblement
des français autour d'un projet autour
d'une équipe autour d'une ville qui il
faut bien le dire concentre l'ensemble
des échecs de la politique menée par les
dirigeants français depuis des années
l'insécurité la division le chômage
l'effondrement économique c'est à tout
cela que louer son équipe vont devoir
répondre maintenant et ils le font j'en
suis sûre est que beaucoup de sérieux
beaucoup de ténacité beaucoup de
compétences et qu'est-ce que vous
inspire la victoire d'edouard philippe
au havre et pour la suite de la
politique ça c'est à lui de décider
il est sûr que il était dans une
situation où il aurait il aurait été
étonnant qu'il ne soit pas élu
c'est d'ailleurs quasiment si je peux me
permettre la seule victoire dans marche
véritablement puisque dans toutes les
autres villes il faut bien le dire
la moisson de grandes villes qu'espérait
le mouvement en marche n'a pas donné de
résultats très très flagrant alors
attendons de voir si le premier ministre
soit resté premier ministre ou s'il
souhaite devenir un maire de toute façon
ça changera pas grand chose à la
politique menée par emmanuel macron